professor what do your average days look
like for example do you wake up at the
same time do you drink the same type of
do you drink coffee and it has to be
this particular type of coffee do you
eat a certain breakfast what does it
look like paint the drawer picture
uh
well i'm a lazy bum
uh
and uh i'm a believer in the um
you know as i was at some point a
revolution right before that uh people
used to work seven days a week uh 12
hours a day or maybe with a short break
on sunday morning
depending which culture you came from i
suppose
and then at some point there was this uh
workers right uh
revolution
and somehow the working week shrunk to
uh
uh 40 hours a week or so like five days
of eight hours
hours a day right
and i'm essentially a believer in that
uh and furthermore i'm a lazy bum so
during my uh eight hours of work a day
five days a week i take coffee breaks i
uh
you know browse the web i cheat
uh
um
but anyway you know i wake up at 6 30 i
exercise take a shower have breakfast
check my email do all sorts of
unimportant things then
around nine usually i start
working
i work until five or so i'm sorry i'm
very dull
and then i try to have fun for the rest
of the day whatever that may be might be
during the pandemic it was it is a bit
harder
and then on the weekends i try to go um
biking hiking
puddling
uh
mostly things that don't have to do with
work i'm lying a little bit because
occasionally there is a reason to work
on the weekend and occasionally i do
have a meeting with somebody like i have
an australian collaborator so often our
meetings are in the evenings
so i mean i'm i i've given you an
idealized uh story the truth is a little
different this you know
varies when you're working from nine to
five how much of that time is spent
thinking versus reading someone else's
paper versus answering departmental
emails and requests like what is work
because work obviously for a professor
you have to teach you also have to do
research there's
perhaps 10. work is all of that and it
depends on the season so
basically when i teach two courses
uh so you know
there's basically fall spring and summer
you know fall
semester spring semester and summer okay
in the fall in the spring i teach either
two or one course per semester in the
summer i don't teach
so when i teach two courses per semester
that's almost
all my attention almost everything i
have
uh goes into that
uh
and the rest goes into the regular
meetings that i have to keep
so i have several graduate students that
i work with several collaborators and
i'm trying to keep weekly meetings with
them
so there is a certain amount of like
weekly meetings that i have to keep
when i teach one course uh i have some
breathing room and when i teach nothing
namely during the summer then a higher
proportion goes into research
even in the summer the proportion is not
very high